sorry buddy well the mail boring-ass
involved apologies for absence I have
guests George enugu still demand Egypt's
amount of the multi counselor Tony
mountain castle you Paul's counselor
mrs. Hughes council Hawai Ian
experimental everybody heard the award
the two thousand occasionally he was
going away apology so perhaps these
apology think the gap with already
Phyllis colleges as well and we have to
substitute català this is Mason is
substituting for terminating and
counselor Stanley you substituting Fred
Kaplan google will begin with
Anastasia's of cytosine and no members
attending the box worry yes then welcome
you all had copies of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 18th is January 2007
thing is everybody happy that assign
those as an excellent record great
declarations latest okay really he comes
up to the cause of making plays let's
nap first item on the agenda is a report
from three gateways trading GM foods we
see the progress was falling the
director the brink of a striking two
changes before we hand over to Dorner's
dark chairman
gateway GM trading cuz I'm so few words
on behalf of the group if you like and
probably with my officer happens of Head
robbing as a director just wanted to
highlight some of the key success
included put things in perspective it
has been a success story chairman thus
far and hopefully in the future and the
project was was set up with the
resistance of members and offices around
the table special Marcus and in others
it was delivered under budget on time
which is great we did the whole things
out the group and the DM company in less
than six months where some councils can
take two or three years the company is
now fully operational and doing very
well some of those successes and will no
doubt done with and others will cover
and the company in profits already it's
forecasted to be profit you know mixed
financial what year all being well it
drew down 25k of the fish and cade line
facility available from the council and
it's in it's on track for paying off
most that allows depending on what the
directors decided to do which is also
very good even though the council's
around it the money and it's going to
meet its targets of 109,000 into power
of of savings and recharges over
previous contract and recharges for
officer time which goes back into the
council their coffers it's already one
business from various parish councils
which Richard Hammond dog may go into
more detail along which is excellent
given the company's only been running
for about since december three months
and and we're in that in the company
should be in a position to pay pay a
dividend back to the council its
shareholders
which rob what they mentioned and later
on he did it may go we have to go
further than that maybe invest back into
the company and so a success story all
around just was a highlight to keep
pointin that wasn't lost in translation
and that's down the continued success
now I think he's down to dawn Matt and
an adam who are the director for the
company if you're running the show
really professionally and making sure
it's providing a good service and is
profitable I just wanted to mention
those points are all handy back to do
thanks very much of that and I am very
pleased to actually be presenting the
first director sport report to the
investment boredom its shareholders and
I was going to run through some of the
activities the formation of the company
some of the priority areas as we were
informing that company were put up to
full recruitment of staff and with the
proof is that supervisor so it proved to
be particularly good for us in
motivating the staff that we have that
was recruited and has built a really
reliable team for us and so far it's
worked out really well our priority area
was around training of staff we
determined house training winter the
council Health and Safety Officer and
we've done some industry appropriate
training as well stuff and that in
itself for the guys out there was really
important to them as well that they had
to for training and its really
appreciated from them but the company
branding and the logos also were
important because the staff been felt a
sense of belonging to the company's the
new company you know from the previous
Isis and they obviously we're coming in
we didn't know I and
game branding actions very important and
so the logo that we now have is really
important to them and have like no she's
seeing that they have been going round
now with bright yellow with the logos of
the back look quite striking we did with
your risk assessments we did a lot of
work around policies for the staff and
some really big a lot of time and those
things people beginning we thought that
was really important we've adopted some
of what's a difficult as policies as
well turn around face guarding policy
and we also our company secretary ranges
for us regular board meetings and i
think we probably had at least four of
those and regular you know the very
formal board meetings which is what the
company secretary mr. haddle government
decision-making meeting directive some
accompanies expected and we are a
fledgling company and you know we have
limited resource but Adam actually done
an excellent job in the tenders around
the parish councils tendering we suppose
in for us but also having to be aware of
that machinery that we have actually
where we can structure is also avail but
a couple of smaller other projects as
well that one off but then we've been
successful in in getting which is also
held and this is obviously a very
positive coverage through the press and
probably seems I've been on a tractor
and mower and I learn series of pictures
around the district which has been
really good and we've had some positive
feedback around that and I think for us
for the future of the company for the
strategy and what we're going to look at
we're now coming into the busiest time
through march in September and what we
really want to do is to focus on
delivering the contracts now with the
resource we have and making sure that
this standard and the quality of work
that we produce is a good high quality
as I say we have now a number of of
parish councils that we're also going to
do the work for what we need to then
understand is what that route looks like
the supervisor has been walking those
rooms we've been out with them as well
they've been doing some of the training
but it now it is about delivering high
quality service and we want to build a
good reputation and also we want the
branding to be really strong out in the
district and that will assist us also
looking elsewhere further into the year
once these other four-year will then
understand the understan d where there
may be issues and they need to look at
issues but also we need to sleep the
expectations of these contracts so from
home October really following the busy
period we're going to be looking and the
director we're looking to begin to
assess the year both operationally and
financially to make sure that we're
still in a really healthy position that
we're in now and and we will be looking
at forming what that business case looks
like informing the strategy to the
features of a sort of business but we
feel we need to have a full year first
to completely get through the council
contractors that can be contract and in
summary then really the company has done
well we've really pleased to be part of
that it was quite unknown territory for
us modesty this is the first letter
accompanying for the Rockford so it's
really nice to be part of part of that
first let go and financially I'll pass
over to rob's and you'd be able to go
through the figures as well for you and
that there's any other questions and
then
any questions at all well done okay long
did you watch coming I can't really
sometimes Ned they're fairly
self-explanatory financial thing was
kind of specific questions so if i'm a
broke through we really just decide as a
company presumably we have to pay taxes
ever of its if so overall I mean is
there like an emotional knowledge in
that we're looking at so corporation tax
revenues twenty percent so basically the
ppt figures we've got here so i profit
before tax we're looking at about a five
thousand-pound tax on either so we're
looking at a net profit of around 20,000
pound of fun that depend on the final
year entities thank you much right so
good and it's just a couple of questions
around these things these are true
december to march this year at choose
four months various contracts income
hundred sixty-eight thousand meaning it
comes out to quite a significant amount
more than we would than was originally
from crosswise that well is the
contractor watch football that's going
around pro rush were here to power half
a million pens which is more than a
tracking system you may attend that
includes the for that that's about the
third one in the quarter includes and
contracts one I the parish contract as
well on top of the district contracts so
the first contractor and hundred basil
pens / 50 desi well thank you will now
make that hundred and sixty-nine no
chances the council's can keep put in
perspective and Rob matches the
council's contract value for the company
is enough for 100 deserved 400,000 so /
whatever they are having 5 of marriage
contracts August wondered if we've
actually actually matched income to the
crap arianism she didn't plan yes it
seems rather high to it I'm not so bad
once at it's good fun not from the
biggest i would expect his scenes I can
i yeah okay thank you em and with the
the wages sorry that but I just need a
bit of some chopped my memory was that
for eight employees the 49,000 yeah I
employees because Donny the destroyer
make 20 minutes it was like tellin
advocate adults that starts up so the
numbers change flights rather marcado's
Macallan 18 wouldn't be accurate but yes
certainly grateful and with regard to
the modern for the apprentices or
musical is not the North cool anymore
god I including support costs because I
instead the oppressors were employed by
the district council and then they
recharge recharge the processing right
here thank you thank you mr. Jim I'd
like to say that these are really
positive report lovely to hear such a
good news that seats on the council and
also very pleased to hear that the focus
is on the ocean because I think that's
very important especially in this area
but the only question of like to autism
it's a little bit confusing here the
financial aid since the first year which
are in the forecast for the next is it
for three months so I was serious
usefully december to march yes yeah not
so it's not a full car feel that your
dish yes we can actual sales so slight
misnomer in here and there that
perhaps from that slight cross-section
just slightly cares about the equipment
hire I accept that yeah that's a normal
way to do things but going forward as
time goes on I think it might be worth
considering looking at both leasing and
purchasing that but certainly not at
this stage that and I wonder if you've
got that in mind City considerate at a
future date yes I think okay is that
them you might be looking at how we
reinvest back into the company and again
that sponsors of the first year the
bidding period we've got some really
good kitten machinery but it may be
fairly looking at actually this will
make us far more efficient so then we
can look at investing and making to the
company that's what would be looking
thank you thank you okay sorry and just
a quick one drop as far as tools and
things that equipment expenditure if you
like really quickly do we that's for
accounting principles is it just a full
rise of the kerchief seems that way we
do it yeah they're big enough that we
would appreciate anything we hired a
minute like satisfying the only reason i
ask is because clearly that towards the
equipment that you've bought you ever
notice of are going now so you know
things like this quarter on yeah that's
that's amusing will see going for those
particularly there may be other pieces
explains in the future so from my point
of view that's that that's a positive if
you like as far as future is a reports
government coming up thank you I think
me just try to catch some mixed emotions
point around and it's just did that I
think it's a decision to be made on
every sort of thing what we know what
they want to pay off of her finally
actually equipment and the capsule great
language versus actually hiring them as
a fledgling company who don't want to be
used up all your capital in the first
instance you will at least get a good
few years under your belt first get a
bit of cattle behind you before you
start bursting because I'll see you want
to do
with that and in the context on the way
so that it's definite enough seasoning
done but mike i would be area on the
caution of going to hiring to the first
few years at least get us it was
established in the market and then start
thinking about individual patterns yeah
i'm quite a very mr. sarin are just
conserve that sometimes when hiring
becomes a norm you forget that the
entire culture and the situation
authorities have leg up so it should be
went for the back of someone's mind is
not welcome hi Mike is it possible in
the future the company could look at
helping private individuals like hedge
trimming massage right again it's a form
of income yeah this episode we've all
looked at hand I feel as up in as homage
likely focus at the moment is on the
quality of the author contacts we've
already got but probably written forward
to next year this 11 thought it would
not reach I consider a senior mummy
lightning were typos charging them so
that residents are aware yeah thank you
right sorry for my cool so don't know
spyware dinner Justin to coyotes on
plane hey mister please I've actually
try 6.1 we put a little bit of Levantine
year we've got cleaned out by trains
limited grounds maintenance I think
we're getting very confused over what
language can be use now because you've
got great play by trading limited brands
makes and so your country number which
is not the right you've got to there are
two companies we've got bring great way
trading limited and green gateway
trading GN limited in Gretchen's and
this should be green gray by trading GM
limited unless the correct number flat
company that's what I'm talking about
and I think we're gonna get incredibly
start getting confused over which
company is doing which reportin which
led to hitting it's basically uses for
it and also on the young forecast slight
no comprehensive income we're calling a
green day trading cgt
the 90 BPM limited their superb three
points I think could be it sounds
technical and it sounds a little bit but
don't pick them up fighting is really
important to make those adjustments
you're right College as they wear it
dirty catering company thank you yes yes
hmm to stop the rock where the support
costs are obtained or what we've got
there is support how that's worked out
and with the tools and equipments as a
second question that we can we actually
owned the small tools and it's only the
largest larger hive of equipment that
we're doing sex it yeah is that right
yes I that's five items with respect the
recharge so what we've got in the
recharge to do so I popped open skating
projects we've got in there the premises
costs we've got the management costs for
obviously running we've got finance and
all death we've got HR and also within
there is the modern apprentices I joined
up across the entire piece it what
happens a 19-percent overhead bearing in
mind a big chunk of that six percent
advantage of modern apprentices bring
out back that you know are running
I behaved support services which in my
opinion it is not that badly a list of
total so it's all along what we're
expecting to like it okay any other
question 43 cherry valley from the video
the loan interest yes that's the book
monsters if I've got something other
should be yes L is that bad ball through
obviously yes and what weight is a
powerful team say okay we had to give a
market right so you've got a fledgling
company we've literally hump day that's
you know impacting oil is always a
change is directed to it and Aurora like
we've been looking at these other
counseling to see will be very careful
at the bridgestone April's and it can't
subsidize the company offering it right
now we have to be seen to be paying
almost more in Mali market in didn't I
suck you I'll tell you can buy that at
this stage of the fledging company's
going whole tree in sounds a bit for
longer comrades but it's actually
actually arena a trigger pulled from
drawn from the right angles here a
fellow trustee has been repaid back in a
month now internet we surround the heavy
though
I think it's a ways and salaries figure
there but there's no mention of pensions
only applies to provide a pinch yes and
it's only nothing its ass again we three
climatic as we go again but just as the
confirm it's not it's not local
authority of india miss it's the nest
nest engine which the private entities
an unconscious later as known question I
had was with vastly important
appointment particularly the large
equipment and have you budgeted for
maintenance as ongoing my maintenance
included in the service contracts are
like so ago these savages it's not extra
cost to us content analysis or 10
section so just come back on flex point
0 Z and the numbers are correct they all
account very much period face because we
have to pay DNT and the egg becomes back
are you prepared a profitable scale
reveal to you we have at that point yes
in some yeah it's awful sorry okay
that's really bad practice it work again
okay we directive relaxing evenings in
Revelation a private activity cubberley
which I should appear no caps go home
and they shouldn't at hand for the 80th
told within the figures at all because
you want the actually that's offline
some of the ones in the bottom may have
the 80 and others may not ok mr. and
it's just really salty if you're sorting
the project and you are giving us a
overstated profit I'll take the point
they probably are expected yet base
because we have to consider this as a
local authority training company or we
can paint the encased in or even element
on I appreciate the assist rip it out in
context but it's interesting that very
good dessert actually give us a little
teasing no because it will wash out it
would be the same as if we had a
contract from the third parties already
it we
finding the item is no more so you
should have it in full of search
committee Jonathan okay well thank you
very much as I can exactly a result
onwards and upwards I'm very
disappointed Thank guys well guys people
that get a sub hey just before we move
on just select members now at the end of
the week after the main meeting we just
have a short short it will be a very
brief there's an update on some of the
other projects that are going on for so
members are kept aware of what's going
on behind the scenes there's not
complement Jerry going three million yes
and it seems a little bored might have
that on their agenda anyway my new roots
there should be at least an agenda item
allows the board which meet periodically
to receive updates on the major projects
and you know it would be yet will be
mine from proposal if you like so that
we do that in future so it is in the
meeting you want comment electrical
justice i channel what we're doing is
the dentistry disagree that when we
jumbo Scott's going to come up with a
proposal which will put through chair
and Vice Chair in terms of how we best
manage this so watch this space
basically normal weather is kept at the
technicalities this is it looking
through chairman if I may Justice
perfectly legal stuff in the updates get
my BP and see something that's be
careful from there was part of the
meeting Nazi P&C because he's really
down the subjective obviously some
projects will
ahead of others look I think that's
really weird generally I think John will
be looking at I thought it was in any
way yeah very point and I'm my dad
today's of course you know the whole
thinking and part of the agenda can be
made pmc there's no reason why I
shouldn't be it's off its operational
reporting and so I wouldn't disagree
with you but what s sa watches like the
silver can somebody balancing okay
moving swiftly on to item 7 exclusive
impressed for the public is able to
catch either a great and that's very
interesting